[Música]
este miércoles suecia y finlandia
presentará sus solicitudes formales para
ingresar a la otan los líderes de los
dos países viajarán el jueves a estados
unidos en busca de respaldo mientras que
turquía se mantiene en su postura de que
no aceptará la membresía de los nórdicos
la supremacía blanca es un veneno en
eeuu así lo afirmó el presidente joe
biden desde búfalo nueva york allí se
reunió con los familiares de las
víctimas que en su mayoría eran
afroamericanas
eeuu suaviza las sanciones contra
venezuela para facilitar los diálogos
entre el gobierno de nicolás maduro y la
oposición la plataforma unitaria afirmó
que hay acercamientos para reiniciar la
negociación en mexico tenemos reportes
desde caracas
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle e iniciamos
con la actualidad suecia y finlandia
entregarán formalmente su solicitud para
unirse a la otan y el jueves la primera
ministra sueca magdalena anderson el
presidente finlandés salin y listo
viajarán a washington en busca del
respaldo del presidente estadounidense
joe biden es que turquía ha dicho que se
opondrá al ingreso de los nórdicos
quienes necesitan unanimidad en la
alianza militar para poder ser aceptados
esto a pesar de la posición de reyerta y
verdú han la casa blanca afirmó que
confiaban en que los países miembros
llegaran a un consenso
suecia y finlandia también esperan el
respaldo del gobierno turco
suecia también quiere cooperar con
turquía dentro de la otan ya
esta cooperación puede ser un elemento
nuevo e importante en nuestras
relaciones bilaterales
por supuesto suecia se opone a todas las
formas de terrorismo al igual que la
otan y la unión europea
con francia intensificará el envío de
armas a ucrania según lo hablaron
telefónicamente los mandatarios de ambos
países aunque el comunicado del elíseo
no precisó a cuánto armamento se
referían emanuel manjón y su homólogo
volodymyr selenski también hablaron de
las garantías de seguridad que el
gobierno galo podría proporcionarle a
kiev y los líderes discutieron además en
las maneras para que ucrania reanude la
exportación de sus granos
y vamos a españa porque intentan
fortalecer el derecho al aborto y es que
el consejo de ministros aprobó el
anteproyecto para ampliar la ley de
salud sexual y reproductiva y de
interrupción del embarazo luego vienen
las votaciones del sector de la justicia
y de los legisladores uno de los puntos
clave es permitir que las mujeres puedan
interrumpir su embarazo desde los 16
años y sin el consentimiento de sus
padres también se plantea una
incapacidad pagada por el estado para
las mujeres que tienen fuertes dolores
menstruales y además que el seguro de
salud proporcione la píldora
anticonceptiva y un permiso de
maternidad adelantado también la
gestación subrogada quedaría
explícitamente descrita como violatoria
de los derechos humanos
pasamos a noticias de américa
el presidente de estadounidense joe
biden visitó la localidad de buffalo en
el estado de nueva york donde el sábado
un joven mató a 10 personas e hirió a
tres más 11 de ellas eran afroamericanas
antes de rendirle un homenaje a las
víctimas del tiroteo masivo el
mandatario afirmó que se trató de un
acto de terrorismo doméstico y criticó
al supremacismo blanco en el país ama al
menos mantiene la historia y el
supremacismo blanco es un veneno el
software es un veneno realmente que se
está extendiendo por nuestro cuerpo
político y hemos permitido que se agrave
y crezca ante nuestros ojos
ya es suficiente amor estas fueron las
palabras con las que el presidente de
estados unidos joe biden condenó el
tiroteo que cobró la vida de 10 personas
en la localidad de buffalo en el estado
de nueva york
by then se solidarizó con las familias
de las víctimas y calificó el ataque
armado que es investigado como un crimen
de odio de terrorismo por lo que ocurrió
aquí es simple y sencillo
es terrorismo terrorismo doméstico según
medios de comunicación locales que
revisaron cientos de mensajes del
asesino en internet el acto fue
meticulosamente planificado durante
meses el sábado 14 de mayo el agresor
condujo por más de 3 horas desde su
pueblo hasta el topes friendly market en
un barrio afroamericano de búfalo
vestido con ropa de combate al el
perpetrador llevaba un arma
semiautomática con la que asesinó a 10
personas e hirió a otras 3 11 de las
víctimas eran afrodescendientes el
tirador está acusado de asesinato
premeditado y deberá comparecer ante el
juez el jueves la tragedia ha vuelto a
suscitar un debate sobre el control a la
venta de armas en el país by then
aseguró que pedirá al congreso tomar
medidas para prohibir que las personas
con enfermedades mentales adquieran
armas y es que según el archivo de
violencia armada en lo que va del 2022
se han registrado en el país al menos
198 tiroteos masivos
la cumbre de las américas no contará con
la presencia de otro presidente el
mandatario de guatemala alejandro
giammattei anunció que no acudirá a la
reunión que se realizará en los ángeles
en junio previamente sus homólogos de
méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador y de
bolivia luis arce afirmaron que tampoco
irían si eeuu se mantiene en su postura
de no invitar a cuba venezuela y
nicaragua además el anuncio de llama
'the y se produjo un día después de que
washington criticara la designación de
consuelo rojas como la fiscal general de
guatemala y es que ella está en la lista
del departamento de estado
estadounidense sobre agentes corruptos
eeuu suavizó una de las sanciones contra
venezuela y le permitió a la petrolera
estadounidense chevron iniciar
conversaciones con el gobierno de
nicolás maduro y también con la compañía
estatal pedevesa aunque chevron todavía
no podrá operar en suelo venezolano
washington sostiene que las medidas para
facilitar las negociaciones entre la
administración y los opositores reunidos
en la plataforma unitaria nuestra
corresponsal daniela zambrano nos amplió
previamente desde caracas
una de las primeras reacciones fue la de
la vicepresidenta del si rodríguez a
través de 'twitter' quien decía esperar
que éste fuera un camino para que se
levantaran todas las sanciones impuestas
contra venezuela' y confirmaba que el
gobierno de eeuu permitiría la
comercialización por parte de empresas
tanto europeas como estadounidenses con
la estatal petróleos de venezuela sin
embargo vale la pena destacar que
trascendió más temprano que el
levantamiento de estas sanciones incluía
que chevron pudiese reanudar
conversaciones con la estatal petróleos
de venezuela sin embargo no se
especificaba que pudiesen comercializar
el crudo venezolano
luego se conoció un comunicado que
difundió la denominada plataforma
unitaria la coalición de partidos
opositores en el que anunciaban que
formalmente se reanudaban las
conversaciones con el gobierno de
nicolás maduro para reactivar el diálogo
en méxico también se difundió una
fotografía con los jefes negociadores de
ambos bandos estrechándose las manos
jorge rodríguez y gerardo blyde con el
mismo mensaje vale la pena destacar que
por parte del gobierno de eeuu el asesor
de la casa blanca para américa latina
aseguraba que sí aliviando las sanciones
en venezuela para que se renovará el
diálogo en pro de buscar unas elecciones
libres y transparentes pero que estas
sanciones podrían volver a ser impuestas
en caso de que no avanzaran esas
negociaciones ahora hagamos un breve
repaso sobre noticias del cobi 19 en el
mundo
los menores que tengan entre 5 y 11 años
en eeuu ya podrán aplicarse la dosis de
refuerzo la administración de alimentos
y medicamentos autorizó la vacuna
adicional y anunció que esta debe ser la
de facer biotech
la ciudad de nueva york aumentó su nivel
de alerta por kobe 19 y ahora está en
alto ya que las sub variantes de omicron
han hecho que el virus se propague más
rápido y ha presionado otra vez al
sistema de salud por la medida se
recomienda usar mascarillas en lugares
cerrados y evitar espacios concurridos
las autoridades también recomiendan
continuar la vacunación como medida para
combatir un rebrote
y la organización mundial de la salud
está alarmada por la creciente
propagación del coronavirus en corea del
norte el organismo de la onu advirtió
que la población de este país asiático
era particularmente vulnerable pues gran
parte no está vacunada y reiteró su
oferta de brindar ayuda a la nación en
la pandemia el gobierno norcoreano no
reportaba datos pero en esta ola ha
confirmado que al menos 1.5 millones de
personas han tenido fiebre
y atención a los fanáticos de hollywood
porque en un mes se subastarán varios de
los tesoros de las películas más famosas
del cine a la venta estarán por ejemplo
el modelo de la nave espacial ex wing de
star wars y el martillo de thor en total
más de 1800 objetos estarán en la
subasta que irá del 21 al 24 de junio
profesor uno de los líderes de las
ventas de implementos de películas es
para recaudar entre 7 y 10 millones de
dólares los usuarios también podrán
comprar elementos usados en clásicos
como el joven manos de tijera o pulp
fiction
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
nos vemos próximamente para más
información
[Música]